all right it's time for drew's news your
daily news smoothie with an extra plop
plop of the good news protein powder and
with me at the desk is my trusty
co-pilot rossi ross matthews that is one
healthy smoothie everybody hi hi guys
and a big day around here well speaking
of two scoops of high-powered protein
joining us on zoom are two men who need
no introduction
legends comedians actors and writers who
are now co-hosting an incredible new
podcast that takes you behind the scenes
at the institution that is saturday
night live please welcome the ones and
onlys dana carvey and david spade wow
hello
[Applause]
right
how are you
i'm so good um i just there's so many
things that you've put out into the
world that are so wonderful and you have
this new podcast that really does give
you a fly on the wall from you know
legends from the
almighty institution i was lucky enough
i got to come to your show last week
thank you so much for having me yes you
did yes you were awesome one of our
favorite guests yeah
[Applause]
can i ask you both a quick question like
i'm just gonna pick two
two things that you did um out of my the
top of my head like david when you came
up with hollywood minute how did that
one come about because i i i think about
it all the time it's one of my favorite
things i've ever seen i miss it i love
it
i think the quick answer uh is that when
in those days there was just people
magazine and everyone was sort of just
fawning over celebrities and i was a guy
on snl that no one knew from arizona
younger and i would just i would read
the people magazine at the desk with
like bob odenkirk and other writers and
just go make fun of people oh look at
michael bolton you got long hair in the
back but we all know what's happening on
top
you know you know what i mean yeah i
know you sold eight million albums but i
don't know anybody that has one and then
i would just talk out loud and then
and then
and then he goes why don't you turn that
into something for the news where you
can just deliver him ratatta yeah and
then we did that and then lauren said
why don't you do it again next week and
i was like because you know lauren's
like the dad that he won't like you and
i wasn't doing unbelievably well in this
show so it turned into a a running thing
and it helped me stay on for a couple
more years now like dana church lady for
one where was the impetus i mean come on
i mean
where was the impetus idea light bulb
for that
i'm not totally sure where it came from
i started i was playing uh where i met
my wife in the haight ashbury a
converted laundromat a little comedy
club and i would riff a lot and i looked
12 at the time i looked younger than
david spade and when i came when i came
on stage i could see the audience kind
of go whoa and so i started doing that
condescending teacher attitude of well
well well
apparently they let little children into
the audience theater or whatever
that that's where it came from and then
the condescending it became church
ladies the ones who ran the church and
it just became
um well this attitude is fun to do so
it'd be like oh the drew barrymore show
we have a little set don't we we're
little microphones we talk into but we
don't care too much about jesus
so that's um
i i don't i don't mean to offend that's
just the church
lady she's weird that's the lady she's
kind of mean i'm nice
[Applause]
[Music]
you